all right before we let you go i want to
play a little game i'm basically just
going to throw out names topics phrases
and you just tell me exactly what your
unfiltered thoughts are ready okay
president joe biden
terrible
why
uh ultimately biden just does not know
how to meet the moment he is a bad
president because he is too old he's out
of touch and he's just too much of an
institutionalist look joe biden i've got
some great books behind me great
presidents made you feel as if they
cared about the issues that matter most
to your life honestly you don't even
really have to do anything about it fdr
didn't solve the great depression ever
in his entire term of presidency but he
won three separate presidential
elections because people felt like their
life was being ruined and at least the
guy in power cared look when you pursue
build back better and his voting rights
nobody cares the price of gas is too
expensive my [ __ ] at the grocery store
is too expensive my kid has to wear a
mask during school i can go on these
these are not even necessarily great you
know i don't even have kids but i'm
verbalizing a problem that people have
the country is in chaos people are
miserable the president is not even
voicing a concern about that and that's
what makes him a bad leader okay next
one
president donald trump
yeah trump honestly he had a lot of
promise but his problem at the end of
the day was he just cared more about
himself than he did about the country i
mean i remember so many times in which
trump could have either tried to unite
tried to say something along the lines
of better angels of our nature but at
the end of the day he just cared about
his own personal popularity and he cared
more about you know his ego as opposed
to the to the country he had made a lot
of big promises around building bringing
jobs back to america about fixing trade
with china almost none of that
materialized most of it was just [ __ ]
posting from behind the oval office and
so i would give him uh you know as
not as bad of a grade as biden but
really up there
all right next one federal reserve and
monetary policy oh that's a good one you
know it's it's fascinating i'm sure that
oh god i wish we could do this for like
an hour because we could talk i'm gonna
bring you back like once a month so
don't worry let's do this no because
this is actually something which
requires a lot of nuanced discussion
what i would say the biggest failure is
is around the fact that quantitative
easing in all this was pursued without
any democratic input whatsoever and that
the effects of quantitative easing have
actually caused and created a system in
which people no longer feel any agency
in order to have input either both on
their money but also in how the broader
economy runs and so with the transfer of
both wealth and power to just basically
a very small group of people who are
making all of the decisions which impact
what 70 85 of the global assets it makes
it so that people feel completely
disconnected from the broader global
economy so on that i have to give them a
failing grade just we would probably
even disagree about like where why and
all that but the key is this which is
that the actual legitimacy of americans
have and their faith or have faith in
the legitimacy of their economy is near
zero and honestly it should be the [ __ ]
is fake and so when you realize that
it's a deeply powerful thing and i blame
the fed for a lot of that
next one politicians day trading stocks
oh absolute ban i'm very proud crystal
and i were some of the first people to
draw attention to this with unusual
whales shout out to that guy um back
we've been doing this for over a year
reporting some of these trades absolute
bad we i don't take their word for it
they want us to trust them do you trust
nancy pelosi do you trust dan crenshaw
no the answer to that is a flat note my
favorite was crenshaw recently said that
he needed to be able to trade to quote
better himself listen bro if you want to
better yourself come out here play in
the pl actually start your own business
you can come and add economic activity
you're in congress your job is to better
the lives of your constituents of the
american people so screw you that's what
i really what i have to say to anybody
who defends this stuff